laura is with us to start off this hour
in San Antonio Texas welcome for the
Dave Ramsey show Laura hi Dave hey
what's up my 18 year old mother has
developed a serious gambling addiction
over the last three to four years that
we just kind of a recently discovered
your mother yes yes what is she gambling
on well she goes to the Native American
casinos and she also Gamble's on a
social media game where she doesn't even
win money she just she was spending up
to seven hundred dollars a week
sometimes on this social media video
game that simulated gambling and and so
my question is you know what our success
that you see that we could take to
prepare and turn my dad he's also 82 he
doesn't even know how to turn the
computer on but she's very
technologically savvy this is she's a
brilliant woman who has always worked
really hard and managed for many well so
we think that that this has been brought
on by medication that she's taking that
we're investigating about but in well in
the meantime you know we need to be able
to take control of the finances so that
she doesn't she's already started
borrowing against their house that's
been paid for forever so sorry I'm
willing to relinquish control of the
finances I'm going to try to approach it
you know with as much love and care
where's your dad in this when I see her
why is he not approaching it he kind of
relies on Hanah you know she's very very
smart
and she's she relies on her to turn and
manage everything that she's always done
such a great job does he not understand
that she has a problem
is the problem why he has partnered with
me in our last attempt to do this and in
checks where he actually drives down to
the credit union to check her activity
to see you know what's going on with the
account weekly but I you know I tell him
you know I daddy she can have a credit
card that you don't know about she can
you know there's lots of ways for her to
get money that you don't understand and
it was looking online gambling and that
sort of thing so there's I mean there's
a spectrum of ways you can approach this
and you'd have to you have to be in
touch with someone in elder law someone
who deals with it early in law
situations like this but one end of the
spectrum the easiest end is just to get
her to admit that that's where she is
and she then relinquishes all control
and take her name off of everything and
you unplugged the computer and you know
she's just not allowed to go to the to
the casinos anymore period and and
obviously she has no access to money so
she can't do that unless she you know
and if she's not online she'd be very
make it very very difficult but mom yeah
you know if you have to get her to admit
that she has a problem to voluntarily
relinquish that though and that's gonna
be your dad being more forceful than
he's been he's been listening on this
he's he's gonna have to play on this
he's got to play hard to get her to do
this because she's you know they don't
turn loose of this stuff easy so that
that's way number one and it might sound
like this you might want to also get
with a good family therapist on how to
do an intervention I'm not a family
therapist but on interventions what
we're talking about here and but it
could sound like this mom you've got a
real serious problem and you go through
the whole process of explaining all of
that you're destroying your lives we're
not going to stand by and watch it and
so you're either going to we're gonna do
this easy way or the hard way mom it's
up to you the easy way is is you've met
there's a problem and you relinquish
control the hard way is we're going to
drag you before the judge and have you
declared incompetent
mm-hmm and that's the other hell and
that gets really agnostic really nasty
and you would just you know you on the
basis of you know she's elderly and
she's out of control and she's
destroying himself she's a financial
danger to herself and her loved ones and
so it's not negating - you're protecting
your inheritance since you got protect a
place for your dad to live and her to
live out their lives financially we have
a beautiful life I just want to make
sure that she has beautiful you know the
rest of her life as well exactly and
this is not bringing joy to her in any
way
addictions never do so you know you just
got a it's gonna be a very very hard
series of things but basically you've
got to go through every single account
and take her name off of everything and
we've got everything down shut her
access down she has no access to the
checking account I go stir all straight
to your dad's name and you and your dad
can watch over it and you can take care
of her
and but when you've got 700 a week going
out on a social media game we got a
problem
mm-hmm a matter of consulting the
attorney what it would mean to her own
social security friends her account so
that she can't take out any lines or
credits or that sort of thing I mean you
can you can even put a label on her
credit bureau report that would show up
if somebody she tried to pull alone that
just says you know she's been she's the
power of attorneys been assigned due to
dementia or something like that and just
put something on there like that that
just they go without shaming her and but
just take her take her abilities away
from her across the board but you can't
do that without her permission or the
court's permission yeah she's an adult
you can't you're not just you don't
legally have there I don't have to
legally have the right to you know
assign all of these labels to you Lauren
I can't walk in and just do this to you
but if I cared about you and we were
close I could drag you before the judge
and judge with a series of evidence
declare you to be incompetent if you
weren't voluntarily willing to do that
but that's what needs to happen here
you're right you guys are you and your
data and your dad's gonna have to really
be more forceful than he's been I really
since he stands in the background and
just kind of rings his hands and and
she's been kind of wearing the pants in
terms of forceful personalities in this
discussion so that's getting ready
change because that's the only shot
you've got at the intervention actually
working but again I'm not a therapist
you guys check with somebody that has
good family counseling maybe participate
with them maybe a pastor of their church
participate someone that's got
credibility and her eyes that you can
move her the easiest path by far it's
for her to accept that she's got a
problem and just voluntarily turn this
stuff over but it's you know it's a very
difficult process you're entering into
I'm so sorry
folks the second fastest growing
addiction in North America today is
gambling the internet has caused an
explosion and gambling addictions we see
them in here every week with financial
problems we're looking at their
financial problems the fastest-growing
is online porn the addiction of that is
by far those two are explosively quietly
behind closed doors exploding
[Music]